con éxito
les presento a fernando delgado
él nació el 10 de septiembre del 89
sus papás tuvieron que esperar tres años
después de casarse para concebirlo así
que ténganlo por seguro que era un niño
muy deseado y planeado cosa muy rara hoy
en día verdad
sus papás le dieron todo lo que
necesitaba inclusive un poquito más de
lo que necesitaba para desarrollarse
plenamente como persona tuvo una
infancia común
pero desde muy pequeño se sintió
diferente realmente se sentía distinto
sus compañeritos del kinder de la
primaria se burlaban de él porque le
decían que actuaba como niña
es duro para cualquier niño no saber no
entender porque se están burlando de ti
simplemente te estás expresando qué pasa
su mamá lo metió a karate era evidente
que los niños eran muy crueles así
pasaron los años y fernando aprendió a
actuar como se supone que tiene que ser
bajo esta heteronormatividad azul niños
rosa niñas
pasaron los años y a la edad de 16 años
por azares del destino entró por primera
vez a un bar gay donde había show
travesti
a fernanda sus papás de alguna manera le
cambiaron el no por el poder tú puedes
no era no puedes hacer esto era tú
puedes hacerlo distinto
entonces no les daba miedo hacer nada y
dijo yo quiero hacer show travesti
porque no
es ahí en este show donde descubrió a
fernanda delgado
desde que nacemos se nos sexta en base a
nuestros genitales y junto con él y es
la primera etiqueta que tenemos al
llegar a este mundo junto con esa
etiqueta se imponen una serie de
expectativas sociales que si no
cumplimos se nos va a criticar se nos va
a juzgar y se nos va
a volear
qué sería de nosotros si tuviéramos una
sociedad informada que sepamos la
diferencia entre identidad orientación o
preferencia sexual y expresión sexual
son cosas totalmente distintas
pero casi todos siempre queremos
basarnos
en nuestros genitales
eso es lo que siempre nos diferencia del
tú puedes o no puedes hacer equis cosas
que sería de una sociedad donde nos
respetemos y donde veamos con agrado
nuestras diferencias
la vida el eje es muy compleja y sobre
todo para las personas trans hace no
mucho hace algunos años nuestros caminos
eran muy limitados eran la prostitución
era andar show o el estilismo
nadie nos quería dar trabajo digno
nadie quería tener una mujer o un hombre
trans en su empresa o en su negocio
mucho menos en una institución pública
qué mejor muestra de fortaleza que
enfrentarnos a todos estos prejuicios y
evolucionar hasta ser hombres y mujeres
de bien sin la necesidad de estar
peleados con la crítica
a los 24 años
me metí de lleno al activismo
para mí era muy sencillo pasar
desapercibida porque cumplo con los
estereotipos físicos sociales y me era
muy cómodo pasar desapercibida hasta que
descubrí que tenía un don el don de mi
voz
y es por eso que estoy aquí con ustedes
utilizando mi voz
para crear puentes de empatía para
derribar muros para cruzar fronteras de
ignorancia
a mí a mis años de activista he conocido
muchísimas historias de muchas personas
lgv bueno ven muchísimas personas ya me
agarran muchos amigos como psicóloga
conocí la historia de alejandra una
mujer trans de 40 años con dos intentos
de suicidio ahorita está en un centro de
rehabilitación para hombres pese a que
se ve físicamente como una mujer
ella no tuvo la infancia que yo tuve
ella a los siete años sus hermanos los
descubrieron con un vestido de su
hermana la golpearon hasta dejarla
sangrado en el piso
sus papás con un afán de quitarle lo
la mandaron con un tío para que
le quitara lo afeminado ese tío le puso
el mismo vestido con que le encontraron
y se la llevó por todo el pueblo arriba
de un burro y le dijo eso es lo que te
va a pasar si quieres ser mujer todo el
mundo se va a burlar de ti
el tío se la llevó a trabajar a la
agricultura
el tío es muy macho
la violó desde los 6 hasta los 10 años
ella se salió de su casa
y es un claro ejemplo de la superación
saco su carrera no cualquier carrera
luego quiso hacer conductora de
televisión
pero qué le pasa a un ser humano tan
empoderado tan fuerte para pasar estas
adversidades que hoy en día ya dos veces
se trata de quitar la vida y tiene una
adicción a las drogas muy fuerte
obvio esa cicatriz que le dejó el pasado
esa cicatriz que le dejó su familia no
es fácil de superar
también conocí a michelle un joven muy
joven alegre feliz con una chispa
impresionante si tú lo hubieras conocido
no te hubieras dado cuenta de lo que
estaba sufriendo en casa un día de
buenas a primeras de él se ahorcó del
mismo árbol donde su papá lo amarraba
porque no se le quiere quitar la foto
roberto un señor de 65 años que duro con
su pareja 38 años viviendo juntos
creando un patrimonio compraron su
casita compraron sus muebles sus cosas
necesariamente su pareja falleció y
todos estos bienes estaban a nombre del
finado la familia del finado como no
estaba de acuerdo con su relación lo
dejó en la calle a sus 65 años ustedes
creen que no es importante ver hacia los
derechos igualitarios hacia el
matrimonio igualitario hacia la
identidad de género hacia la adopción
homoparental ustedes creen que no sea
importante crear una conciencia en las
personas de lo que sufrimos las personas
lgbt
ésta solamente es una pequeña probadita
de lo que pasa aquí en zacatecas en un
estado tradicionalista y conservador
doble moralista diría yo
a cuántas personas trans conocen ustedes
apuesto que ninguna osea caso a una
yo conozco aproximadamente 350 personas
trans aquí en zacatecas estamos por
todos lados somos obreros empleadas
enfermeras arquitectos psicólogos
maestros ingenieros servidores públicos
estamos por todos lados pero no se es
más cómodo pasar desapercibidos no sé es
más cómodo colarnos entre la sociedad y
pasar invisibles ante la crítica y ante
los prejuicios sin sentido
apenas en el 2018 la organización
mundial de la salud excluyó la
transexualidad de su lista de trastornos
mentales según un estudio internacional
en el 2006 por la organización de
estados américanos se sacó una cifra de
que las personas trans mueren antes de
los 40 cualquiera de ustedes pensaría
que es por el tratamiento de reemplazo
hormonal por las cirugías o por todo lo
que tenemos que hacer para sentirnos
cómodos con nosotros mismos pero no es
así esa cifra es por todos los crímenes
de odio que han pasado que han suceda ha
sucedido hacia nosotros esa cifra es por
la cantidad de suicidios que se dan por
la violencia y la discriminación hacia
nosotros
si bien es muy fácil juzgar a la persona
por su apariencia pero porque no nos
quitamos esas caretas porque no vemos
que hay dentro de nosotros como ya lo
mencionaba en algunos compañeros quién
eres
bueno les podría decir que fernanda es
una mujer libre valiente y feliz
es una mujer que no le teme a nada no
tengo una carrera de derecho y soy
servidora pública no soy comunicóloga y
tengo un programa de radio digital
que sería de la sociedad si todos
fuéramos así si todos fuéramos valientes
libres y felices
porque hay infinidad de ejemplos como la
sociedad no somos libres algo tan fácil
alguien que quiere estudiar artes y sus
papas y sus papás le exigen que estudie
medicina porque el papá y el abuelo son
médicos
hay infinidad
de ejemplos de cómo la sociedad de cómo
nuestra propia familia o de cómo
nosotros mismos no nos permitimos ser
libres ser valientes y ser felices
quitémonos nuestra careta sólo somos
personas
[Aplausos]